look back at your ancestors look back at
your your grandparents look back at what
they did
what they lived through the seas that
they planted that you can afford to be
in the circumstance that you are in
today
if you are a black american and you are
breathing in the united states today
you are the luckiest among the luckiest
of black people that have ever lived
anywhere on the face
of the planet that is an incredible
statement all of human history
the luckiest black people that have ever
lived on the face of the human planet
are the ones that are living and
breathing
in america today okay if you understand
that
and you should understand it by simply
saying where would you like to live in
africa
for all that that that that hoopla about
they took us from africa find me a a
black american that will tell you they
want to move back to africa i will
listen right now or europe
i'll book the flights for them all right
for any person that says we were stolen
from our ancestors i can of someone's in
pledging
that i will book the flights if you were
announced your u.s citizenship for you
to go live back in africa
all right so speaking of books i don't
have a copy of black out here
because the galleys have not arrived yet
they have not arrived the galleys are on
the way
i know that a lot of what we discussed
here obviously is what blackout
is about but what what maybe did i miss
or should we should we hit on or you
know so blackout for me
it was i really wanted to first and
foremost lay out my personal story
there's been a lot of conjecture about
where i came from how i became
conservative is she a fraudulent
conservative and
all of that craziness because people
don't realize that i just was a
political if anything else like to be
clear you're not some sort of secret
agent no
remember you really have been there
through all of them i've been there
i mean the youtubers like digesting my
entire life saying like
she must be a plant like i mean a soros
plant i'm like i've never even voted
like i literally prior to getting
getting into things i had i
genuinely just was not politically
inclined um and i just thought i had to
be a democrat and thought i had to be a
liberal and
you know looking in the retrospect i
realized how foolish that is um
you know that i didn't realize that
everything was really that everything
that
bad happened in my life was really
routed to a bad
policies and bad politicians um but i
wanted to first lay out just my personal
story um you know the subtitle of the
book is how black america can make its
second
escape from the democrat plantations um
and i do believe
um i say this all the time people get
upset that black americans are still
enslaved today
that the left just got smarter and they
realize that you you you can enslave
people
um their bodies you can't have black
black americans on the plantation
anymore but you can still have black
americans doing all the work for you
and reaping no benefit and that is a
structure that we see today between
black america and the democratic party
we are doing all the work we get we
carry them over the finish line
and we benefit not in one single way um
and so i really kind of lay out that
argument
um and then talk about what slave life
was really like the breakdown of family
why it was necessary for families to be
broken down
uh to trade constantly be trading um
slaves from one plantation to the nut to
the next they could they could have no
feelings for one another
at frederick douglass uh in his
autobiography the first couple of pages
and he starts talking about his life as
a slave
uh he talks about the fact when his
mother died he felt nothing uh when his
sisters were treated
he felt nothing he had no sense of
kinship no no familial love
for his own blood that was necessary to
the institution of slavery we still have
that kinship and that relationship and
that community still broken down
all of these years later later despite
the reconstruction era post slavery
uh which we saw black american families
getting back together we were we were
doing something um it's all been wiped
out at a higher rate by the way
until about 72 or so yeah in the 1950s
uh black americans were outpacing whites
in terms of economic growth
and then immediately following you know
the the 1960s and the great society act
um and the systemic oppression which
started via the welfare system
everything started falling apart
um and uh reading another another topic
talking going back to slavery uh black
americans it was illegal for black
americans to learn how to read
in fact it was so illegal that if you
were a white person you were taught
and you were and you were caught
teaching your slave to read you would be
found guilty too it was a serious sin
the reason for that is uh because they
didn't want black people being educated
because an educated mind can't be
enslaved
well what's changed look at the literacy
rates in black america today
look at baltimore look at the inner
cities look at where in california
california
70 percent of black boys could not pass
a basic literacy exam
nobody is talking about that you have
politicians that are standing on stage
saying that all they care about is black
americans they're not talking about
everything that is harming black
americans today everything that is
recreating
the very same plantations that we came
from did you catch that brilliant line
that bernie had in one of the debates
which is he wants he's not only so
pro-marijuana that he wants it to be
legal
but he also wants to have uh black
community blacks
black business owners owning black
marijuana shops
right in black communities i did not
catch that and again i say this i say
this as someone that's pro legalizing
but like we're going to incentivize
black people to own
black marijuana right shops in black
communities that that
right and that's and that's why i don't
celebrate by the way why i am
conservative on the marijuana front is
because when you talk about
where this is happening chicago i think
just passed you know marijuana laws
it is to me i i i know it's it's going
to lead to more dysfunction
um you know amongst black america first
and foremost because that's how it
always is
you know it's it's what is it about
progressive policies that always leads
to progressive results for the black
community
first and foremost and um so i i
am loathe uh to to be smart enough to
see the debate between
alcohol and marijuana so that i can't
firmly say
marijuana but i have a thinking brain
and i just don't see how conservatives
can make a sound argument against it at
the moment
what else has to happen for the black
community to break
i'm gonna guess although i don't have
the book yet that at the end you're
gonna you either make some predictions
or you
tell people what tools they need to
really break out of this
yeah you know it's it's not even about
making predictions and i have my own
personal predictions but i definitely am
not doing that in the book i'm giving
black americans a guide i'm giving
giving black americans an option uh the
same option
that i saw before me when i started
waking up and i'm having this
conversation with you
um you can you can have the option to
accept this victim narrative right you
can have the
option to say i accept this diagnosis of
cancer even though i feel fine walk fine
and have been living fine my entire life
i accept that it's terminal illness and
i'm gonna live like i'm gonna die
any moment or or you can you can develop
a different perspective
and you can develop a victor mentality
as i say forget the victim mentality
develop a victor mentality
um look back at your ancestors look back
at your your grandparents look back at
what they did
what they lived through the seas that
they planted so that you can afford to
be in the circumstance that you are in
today
if you are a black american and you are
breathing in the united states today
you are the luckiest among the luckiest
of black people that have ever lived
anywhere on the face
of the planet that is an incredible
statement all of human history the
luckiest black people that have ever
lived on the face of the human planet
are the ones that are living and
breathing
in america today okay if you understand
that
and you should understand it by simply
saying where would you like to live in
africa
for all that that that that hoopla about
they took us from africa find me a a
black american that will tell you they
want to move back to africa i will
listen right now or europe i'll book the
flights for them
right for any person that says we were
stolen from our ancestors i can of
course i'm pledging
that i will book the flights if you
renounce your u.s citizenship for you to
go live back in africa you want you want
to cap this at maybe 10 people just in
case people are punking
there's none we did this we did the same
craziness with the trump i hate america
everyone offered their money in flights
i think you might have died
nobody took nobody took the bait right
because they know
america is the greatest place they could
possibly live um and
you know what if someone takes you up on
this i'll guarantee one one first class
upgrade
that's amazing i will do that there we
go right here first class upgrades
go to america but you have to renounce
your citizenship to america
and move to africa that's really what
you want to do if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell